in cafe au less presto la cafetera
mascarpone llevaba lo zucchero you
cioccolato e sub 0 ard formaggio Masika
pour SE los cojones so the basic the
basic idea the basic idea of the recipe
is how many of you have done done
tiramisu before quantity going quantity
boy I know but to tiramisu nobody here
Pamela hello episode yeah ferrika fan SI
para la woven de parada say para el agua
de monterrey Muntari jianchi yeah so so
wispy x and then
mix in Mescalero mask opponent prema
prema con no no no numa con el primero
de agua important anymore do you guys
plan workload than your car and then and
by voice echoes Tricia Tanaka's plateau
I'll see you requested I Scotty Casey
camera no Odyssey my camera so solid oh
yeah how are you everything sorry yeah
sorry yeah sorry yeah I don't know show
you in 10 so yeah yeah and yeah so so
lady fingers and the the the translation
I don't know where the translation comes
from dita d today dawn but some Orion is
because of the Savoy's were a royal
family so you know until he gets better
Chris Bailey sorry yeah Papa that's it
so that's a lotta aid we dip them in
grappa no you know you did see a dime no
no no no yes Nick a fan look a fan we go
no tengo novio America van ERT like a
fan appointing anema she misses littell
approaching lost rato de crema
consequence of this again if is meeting
for the early Pharaoh they see they
respect our we have to get away that's
the time it's to wait until it gets all
over the sample if you can actually what
so it's really a wawa let walk let you
all know that's a that's kind of an
Italian reflection that's very good okay
so let's separate the eggs and let's
start making coffee do you guys know how
to make coffee with these
so la more like a 58 so this is this is
so this is the funny man with this is
the electric eye and seeing is the mocha
espresso here it's actually the mock
express way from Italy actually very
original so so the cafeteria and so it's
a it's simple you feel you fill the
reservoir with water and you fill it up
so so that when you saw that when you
put you put the receptacle or just the
there's no not a lot of water here maybe
maybe just a little little drop then you
put the then you put the machine lat in
here let me Sheila that has the right
matching up one with that one would hope
then because because these guys do know
what they're doing and then then you
press it a little not too much some
people press it a lot because they want
to cream your coffee by the gym but
generally when you use these machines
it's it's hard for a lot of pressure to
build up and actually have the same type
of creamy coffee that you get you can
say when when you go yeah eat when you
go to stomach so we do go to it to to a
cafe and then then you fill this with
coffee you pat it yeah get it down and
then you that what's up you put it on
the stove and then and then at all the
sudden the coffee will come home from
here and then a certain point this thing
will the single bubble and make
make a little bit of noise that's when
you turn it off and then you does the
[ __ ] yeah that's pretty cool right yeah
doesn't it like isn't like an it is like
very swiftly I can go to burning yeah
that's right so as soon as you you have
to when you don't let it you don't let
out let it make too much noise as soon
as it is it as soon as it starts to boil
you'll hear it and that's when you would
you turn it off so they will take it off
the stove so it doesn't work XO and so
this is this is our I think this is a
mocha mocha that's my lucky color see an
immaculate and I have for sequester man
walking I don't know yeah it seems like
this is mike everywhere inmates and this
is quite it yes so so you say so you say
these things these things well my mac in
a landmark another now who know nor
machina that right it's the amount of
cops that you do ye tu todo esto SI
Yogi's on you I've yah mo B zona de
tanto cafe para para sorry Rin Tin
genetic variant injury oh yeah okay so
we need a lot of coffee to get to the
suburbs alright llamo te ando ando
Montana or I will yank Hannibal files I
jung chanwoo that will get you VIP
little girl we're going to use 68 so
again we can double we could probably
double if you two guys if you guys want
only six thanks we might you might want
to make 12 and we'll just double book
double to go make one
go